hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my readers mal and also from GT
who are members in my forms and they
were asking me about how to keep your
facebook account personal separate than
your business and I thought the easiest
way to show you a bit actually to you do
a screencast you can see what I'm doing
on my computer's answer the question so
the question first of all start with mal
and you're saying I started a Facebook
account must admit I didn't and still
don't get involved much I want to keep
my friends and family strictly separate
appreciate any help in setting up
business page but more importantly how
to keep it separate from the personal
side and then GT responded hi Milo sure
concern its exact reason why I'm not on
Facebook I want to keep personal and
business separate so i thought i'd show
you what i do on facebook on my business
side and personal how I keep it separate
and how I really enjoy the facebook
experience so I'll show you first of all
my business side and what I do so this
is my business page and it's called Evan
Carmichael calm and on the left side
here shows my picture and information
about my website and what I do here is
on my wall I'll share information that
my customers and my readers will I think
enjoy so we start off with famous
entrepreneur quote so I try to do one of
those every morning so this is Steve
kaol I'll do fun things like fill in the
blank so my favorite way to mark my
business is and we get people who then
leave their comments below I'll promote
new videos that I'm working on so a lot
of times when I do these ask Kevin
videos are posted to my facebook page
and then people will like it and comment
on it and share it and that helps spread
the word about the content that I'm
creating and also creates a little
community of people who are
entrepreneurs who enjoy reading my stuff
and they also get to meet each other and
interact which is great I thought I'd
also should break down some of the other
things that I do you have a lot of
opportunities here on the side to add
tabs so the first tab that I added is
inspirational quotes so this is
something that I believe in if you
the success of famous entrepreneurs and
so you know starting the business can be
tough and running it can be even tougher
and here are some inspirational quotes
to kind of keep it going and get you to
want to push through those barriers and
make sure you keep pushing towards that
success the photos tab here these are
any photos that get posted from your
account so while photos I'll often post
photos of famous entrepreneurs when I
have their quotes so this is the founder
of ikea here i created a new line photos
called who's Evan meeting so when ever I
go and meet with people I snap a picture
and i'll post it up on facebook if they
want some promotion i post some fun
pictures and these might be personal
pictures but I get to choose when I want
to put up some fun pictures so it could
be mean salsa dancing or anything from
my personal life that I want to add in
there but it's not required so I have to
separately post to my business page you
say yes you want to put these personal
pictures up and then if I go on TV or
whatever books I'm reading I post post
those pictures up here as well and helps
people get to know me and when I'm up to
but I keep it pretty professional I
don't share you know personal views or
too many personal pictures only a couple
I can put my youtube channel up on here
so it'll show you my most popular
YouTube videos people can watch from
within here and then quote some Oprah
Winfrey tony robbins and you can keep
going on and adding more and i'll
probably keep adding more and more of
those taps in and then you can also
support your friends in business if
other people you know have facebook fan
pages you can put their links in here
and then they can also get some
promotion from your page so that's what
I try to do I find it's a great way to
be able to connect with my audience and
also showcase some of the content that
I'm working on and get feedback from the
community but I keep it strictly
business except for a few personal
photos that I like to put up there I
think it's fun I'll flip back to the
personal side and that's just if I go to
facebook com then this is my personal
feed and has nothing to do with my
business side so here are my friends so
I only add people on my facebook the
personal side who are actually friends
of mine on the business side and we have
couple thousand people who are fans of
the page and you know I know some of
them but most of them I don't have a
personal connection with but on the
personal side I'm friends with all of
these people I know who they are you
know been to their house and interested
to learn more about what they're up to
so here I can go you know see a friend
of mine Alfred k i'll scroll down and
see other you know photos of friends
what they're up to you know my sister my
poster our uncle unfortunately passed
away recently so people posting messages
about him and so that's you know great
way to be able to stay in touch with
friends and family and see what they're
up to my father here was not on Facebook
that much and I said hey you should go
on don't worry about accepting every
friend request just put you know friends
and family who you actually know and you
know i'm i live in the same city as my
were pretty close but my one sister is
in Africa and other sisters in
California and so it's not always easy
to get together and talk but Facebook
can be a great way for people to be able
to share what they're up to and you can
quickly see what everybody's doing
especially in there faraway places so I
don't have to share that much on here
just things that I want to share with my
friends and family will go on my
personal feed and the things i want to
share with my readers go on my facebook
page and that's really why facebook set
up these pages was to separate it from
your personal side because people were
setting up their individual accounts and
promoting their business so they want to
try to keep that separate so I'm a big
advocate of being able to use a Facebook
page I think it's a great way to connect
with your audience and showcase what
you're up to and I hope the video helped
explain how to keep that personal side
different from the business side if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up if you have more questions let
me know and hopefully I can help answer
those too and I'd also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment below the video and stay
tuned to the next episode